Whoa Wait, you're you're not live, right?
Okay, she can okay.
I'm live.
I'm live now Just so you know I'm I'm also live now I can't
tell you guys about my address and where I live anymore.
Oh, yeah, don't worry.
I can still say it out loud I can don't worry.
I'll just repeat it so everybody knows for sure So it was
like Can you remind me the you guys talking you guys are
talking and i can't hear nobody oh yeah oh yeah no they're
talking in game damn it they're talking okay i'm putting it
up as fast as i can any settings that you would recommend or
anything in this game no i don't know tell her to get in the
lobby and we'll tell her yuki says to get in the lobby true
true see you look up too much shit okay see you see you all
right we're just waiting for snuffy
we i love how i love how we were like nobody's live and the
snuffy came in was like oh shit and then left she just
immediately assumed the absolute worst she was like oh no
they must be discussing like trade secrets oh no the mda
leaks no all right we're just waiting for every single
project I'm going to be a part of for the next six years And
she broke everybody Oh no You're going to break your
contract NDA all for content Warning all for the content
Anything for content If this video hits 100,000 likes I'm
going to leak everything
Real I'll leak Everything for 100,000 likes not even for
money i'll do it for likes only that's how much i love
that's fucking right and i'll do it again wonderful it's all
about the algorithm baby remember hit that like button
subscribe hit that notification bell and also comment on my
channel to boost up the algorithm follow my twitter yeah
follow my twitter yes Twitter follow me on Twitch follow me
on YouTube and also follow no you can't skip this ad and
also use my gamer subs code dokeybird oh shit oh you're that
type of content creator no I really not no it's okay lime
own it lime you gotta No judgment here!
No judgment here!
Hannah, I would never judge you live!
Guys, if you tier 3 sub to live right now, you'll get access
to your secret Snapchat.
Hey Sophie!
You gotta make sure you turn the audio to like really low
because this game's audio is fucking terrible.
It's a funny- I just like- I think I just like maxed it on
my stream.
Oh, you maxed it bro.
You're fucking great Like what you hear in this room is not
as bad as Hello
Haan is just standing there like hey Somehow he's the
loudest.
Oh my god.
How is Haan the loudest?
He didn't even say anything you can actually turn the turn
us up and down individually if you hit escape top right um i
had to turn push to talk on because my dog is playing with a
squeaky toy you should probably like i'm just gonna test you
can't hear me nothing bad will happen i was just wondering
how the fuck are you the loudest hon you're literally barely
said anything oh yeah true you can hear his voice even
smoother hey the dlc to get hd oh yeah are you holy you are
allowed what the fuck hello wait how do you guys get funny
oh yeah yeah you can yeah you can change your face yeah you
can draw a penis default dm what's that you can like rotate
it as well what the fuck is that i think i fucked it up how
do i get rid of this there you go oh you have deleted your
face you have just had to clear it up oh are you what are
you trying to do oh okay oh no no no no no no i was like
what the fuck are you doing it's peter griffin guys this is
a christian oh yeah it does look like peter griffin the ball
chin oh this one's kind of swag actually i dig that what
color are you guys i want to be blue i'm red i am green i
have no idea what color i think there's no yellow yellow
wait let me look at your faces let me take a quick look for
reference all right that's me a bunch of tits you're just
very happy very content okay and you're quite the opposite
cool andy all right some good faces wait hold on your
fucking icon sonic Stop!
I was like, what the fuck is this guy on my screen?
Oh my God, it is.
It's like Sonic 1 Sonic.
Yeah, the OG Sonic.
The guys here, fucking- I love the wagging finger Sonic.
That's like the most iconic, not- You're gonna change it,
Steve.
Oh, the guys here, Keanu Reeves is gonna be Shadow.
I'm so excited.
I am so excited for it.
It's gonna be amazing.
Oh my God, for the casting for them.
I feel like all the budgets went to casting for that movie.
Is Sonic even like somebody cool?
It's just like a guy, right?
No, no, he's not just a guy.
He was in like, he was in DuckTales.
For real?
Yeah, he was one of, he was like Louis Dewey and the other
guy.
I don't remember when he was one of them.
He was Huey, no fucking way.
He was Huey, bro.
That's my favorite one.
I can't believe you just called him but some guy I know but
he was actually Huey the duck He was Dewey That's almost as
big as Sonic I know he was just as famous But there's like
what Idris Elba As Knuckles And then Idris Elba is cool
Alright alright Okay so I think that's the guy with the list
I think Snuffy is like the only one Who hasn't played
content warning yet i am yeah she's gonna be the she's like
the intern that we hired for a channel youtube channel so we
send her first right you guys yeah we send her first go down
to the old world wait we should let snuffy hold the camera
then like let her experience recording the for the channel i
just got hired as an editor oh my god you just oh my god and
she's doing it for the experience
youtubers ever i get i can't wait to do it for the exposure
the exposure you can put that on your resume you don't need
eight you get paid you just need views okay so how do i do
this what do i do okay so okay who wants to explain to
snuffy the instructions on being cameraman you gotta point
it at stuff and capture scary things and also you have a
limited amount of tape so good luck does it show you yeah
yeah it shows you on your top right whether Yeah, yeah, you
can also change it to selfie mode if you want to
I don't remember the button You can get the apple.
Why do you want to know?
Oh my god, how did you get the apple?
Howdy folks first day on the job.
How did you do that?
All right Oh my god, there's apples Very good.
You're very special.
Also, Snuffy, just so you know my game tends to bug out and
every time we come back from a mission I lose all microphone
audio So if I like stop talking to you, it's not because I
hate you.
It's just because I don't want to be like anymore Okay, if I
stop talking to you it's because I hate you Okay, okay,
we're filming us with the apple that's content Snuffy Yeah,
I don't have an apple.
I didn't touch apples.
Give us apples.
Film us.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're our apples together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah And apple.
Oh, you drop it like this Burger King commercial?
Oh my credit.
What was it called like those like thirst traps of an apple?
You're gonna make a thirst trap of an apple For the content
I just wasted so much footage.
Okay, okay.
Let's go fucking we gotta make okay.
We gotta go.
Yeah, yeah Nice fantastic.
Let's go.
Let's go like how we didn't we don't need any we don't need
introductions.
We all know who's who Oh, yeah, true.
I can't even see your name i'll just we'll just call you by
your your your color you're calling you red like yellow
where are you yellow okay this is this is where you truly
test the audio snuffy okay this is actually much scarier do
you still have the camera snuffy
she dropped the camera It's okay.
I trust in Han.
Han, I know you're so good at making content.
I got it stuck in my pocket.
I'm gonna go die.
Yeah, yeah, go die for content, Han!
We have to go viral!
For content!
Okay, but you need to die while the camera's rolling!
You can't die without the camera.
That's the point.
Your life will be worthless.
You would have seen it, so that would have been fine.
Yeah, but my- don't have film your life is only worth
something if it's filmed okay okay record him jumping down I
thought you said myth busters I was like oh my god what myth
are we busting today okay it's nothing Just make sure you
film all the content.
We gotta go viral.
I'm in the back here.
I've got the backpack on.
It's okay.
We all know.
The person with the camera can never die.
I think we're gonna die.
No, we're not.
We'll be fine.
What I've learned is that if you go down, it'll eventually
go up.
Oh, shit.
Look, see?
I already got to the exit.
Look at that.
You just found it.
What the heck?
I found the exit.
What was I?
Please!
Phil, that's for the content before we die!
Oh, guys.
Okay.
I'm trying to get ready.
Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil, Phil!
I don't know if you guys are slow, it's all going to be
weird.
Phil, did you get the spider?
It can't be that dangerous, right?
I got the spider.
Okay, yeah, I can't be that.
Oh, my God.
I can't be that dangerous.
He missed.
Oh, we go this way.
We go this way.
It's okay.
He's not chasing us, huh?
And we're okay.
We're so fine.
It's alright.
The beginning level is never that bad.
There's only, like, one really scary monster, and everything
else is fine.
Oh, look at you, Min-Max, and everything.
Yeah, that's right.
That's why I'm a gamer.
Try hard.
Look, you gotta try hard, and you wanna go viral.
studying the algorithm oh my god what hit me what hit me
what hit me what did i got hit by i'm so scared how he had
20 but where the fuck are the others okay but whatever
happens to me yeah sure that you're always running needs
hello oh you're okay you're okay oh wouldn't that be okay
i'd only be bad if i did this
Do you think he's okay?
You're in zone!
Are you still okay?
You're still okay!
You did it!
Yay!
We're fine.
Okay.
Look at that.
What we learned...
Oh.
It's okay.
I have 20%.
What we learned is that you're indestructible.
Just like that M.
Night Shama Lama movie.
You're right.
I should get to that one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe not again.
Maybe not even.
Maybe I should test it out.
Maybe I'm invisible just like you.
What do you mean you don't trust me?
I have the flashlight.
Watch this.
Okay.
Okay, maybe.
You wish.
It's gone.
Sorry, are you dead?
Oh, hey.
Are you...
I just saw you...
I have to take it from my room.
She said she had arachnophobia, so I was just like, Oh, my
God.
Han and I were testing out a theory.
And like, oh, yeah.
I was wrong in my theory.
What was the theory?
Well, we're testing out.
We're both invincible.
And like, well, as you found out, how one of us was it.
What kind of fucking Royce?
You guys sniffing and you're just loading the whole world
and you're like, I think it might be fucking invincible
Look it was like myth busters, you know, like Like we gotta
bust that myth The myth is am I fucking god right now?
Oh, but I'm running I just wanted to know And we just look
he survived it look how?
Han survived?
How is I supposed to know?
I wouldn't survive.
Can you, like, switch with your spectating?
Yeah, yeah, you can't.
With AD.
You must be invincible.
See?
Like, okay.
I was, I half busted the myth.
One of us wasn't invincible.
I was not supposed to know i wasn't the main character like
everyone thinks they're the main character of this story
that might be the most horrific realization is that you're
not the main yeah not even not even on my own stream i'm not
the main character it's so up i am so happy for you oh thank
you yeah believe it that means either of us were not the
main NPC We're fucking NPCs We're like those we're like the
cool kid dude show up for like one episode.
Yeah, and then everybody loves us even though we showed up
for one episode Yeah, but everybody loves us We had to go
here we had to go back to the main lobby guys I was Han and
I were trying to do a myth buster thing and we busted a
myth.
I was not invincible
Snuffy, did you call the spider a dumb bitch as you died?
Yes, she did.
I might have used some language.
We might have to cut that for YouTube.
I'm so excited to see our first video.
This is my first ever content.
Oh my god, your first ever YouTube upload.
You get to hear how fucking awful the audio is once it
actually gets uploaded.
It's great.
Oh my god.
Our first video.
Guys, we got it.
get monetized the first video you're dreaming guys we got to
get 3 000 watch hours so we can get monetized don't forget
to put a bunch of circles on the thumbnail all day howdy
folks first day on the job let's see how it goes yeah can
you drop it in the everking commercials where they drop
losing really hd splashes why is this 50 of the video
Yeah, you left me so little video to actually film the
Spider-Man.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, Snuffy, I found a spy.
Need Destruction Tutorial by Snuffy.
Well,
get out of my way!
Get out of my way!
Alright chat, today we're about to find out if this
Spider-Man web is sticky all my friends would missing now
let's see if this bitch sticks this is pretty sticky
i don't think i can move i don't think i can move my limbs
am i moving am i am i breaking free
that's the freaking last shot of mine good that was really
good story what how many views did we get oh we are 1.5
we're halfway there yeah we're halfway there one day we're
halfway there look at that we're gonna get montage soon guys
that's freaking good that's so good 1k i don't even know
that many people oh my god i can't believe that's where
that's our that's our debut stream 1.5k oh my god we got a
title something good like entangled by sticky web be like
what is it a sticky mess and then we're gonna make clickbait
thumbnail where Snuffy is covered in white sticky web
wait where did the fuck where the camera go Wait, where'd
the fuck do the camera go?
Wait, I gotta go to sleep.
Oh, yeah.
This is unrealistic because it implies content creator
sleep.
Yeah, let's go.
It will not let me sleep.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
Oh, are we going to wake?
Are you...
When are we going to wake up?
Good morning.
Oh, shit.
sleep streams always gives us views yeah i can't wait to
make content oh my god yippee another great day to make
content another great day to risk our lives for views all
right who wants to do the camera next oh yeah what kind of
fun things can we buy now that we're famous content creators
now that we have 200 you get me the gucci we should get the
oh we gotta get the the heal item i'm gonna order the heal
item oh cute i'm gonna order the hug does anybody want to do
we get unlimited hugs yeah well we just can't die also we
might need two more flashlights oh hey there's the camera
all right i'll grab this flashlight door i'm gonna charge it
oh it's charged so basically i have a thing snuffy where i
hug you and then you're gonna be full hp I'll be like hug do
you have to hold this hug I have to hold to hug you and then
like if you're you got zero hp just ask for hugs and I'll be
like oh my god
what do you get what the fuck we had a hundred it's really
useful see what What is that gonna do?
Worth it, worth it, worth it.
What is that gonna do for us?
It's gonna give me so many views.
There's a piece that we come in.
I'm gonna go viral with this shit, don't worry.
You're gonna go viral with the piece side.
Look, look, look, look, snuffy.
That's good, that's really good.
Let's go.
Content time.
I'm gonna get like a signature too.
We all have to have like a fun quirk.
A fun quirk.
I'm a homestuck troll.
We're such a quirky squad.
We're gonna be like the low gang.
What's that?
You know, it's like that that that gang from Logan was it
Logan Paul.
He had like a whole gang and stuff Oh, the low gang was that
low gang?
What is it called?
Team 10.
We're gonna be team 10 What's Logan Paul's Oshimark?
What's Logan Paul is it like a maverick or whatever like
some fucking bird?
I don't know why I know so much about that What?
That's like lore I've never even heard.
Yeah, he's like, that's not what he called his fans.
The Mavericks are whatever the fuck.
Because it was like, based off of like, his fucking bird.
See, I don't even know if he has a bird.
I think that's a helicopter.
A Maverick?
This is sick flip.
Yeah.
Nice.
Holy shit.
That's all right.
Just to scratch.
My god.
It is.
seeing the fucking flop all right who's the leader who's the
team leader i think the person with the peace sign oh you're
true oh god that's me she has the most money apparently
sacrifice sacrifice for the content your new skill don't you
want to be just like your oh she logan paul
he got she got touched where the fuck did he come i think
she went this way what was that did hana get like abducted
yeah i got abducted that's like got touch that's a camera
that's the camera wait no but you don't instant die though
you don't you just get like kidnapped abducted we gotta put
him on milk carton soon i gotta go find him anywhere like
where this oh there he is what's your hp do you need hugs
wonderful time thank you here you are you fully
Thank you.
There you go.
I got traumatized.
Don't worry, the easiest fix for trauma.
He's coming back!
Oh my god!
I just see him like, oh!
Wait, does he still have my camera?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, okay, thank God.
Alright, nothing was lost then.
We...
I only have 31% battery.
Hun!
I think he went up here.
Bye.
Han, where are you?
I hear some googly noises, so maybe it's over here.
Oh, oh, oh, did you hear that?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Guys!
Guys, get out of the stairs!
Get out of the fire!
I know that I got abducted!
No!
Oh, no, let me go!
Let me go!
please oh okay okay okay i see their faces i see it was a
setup i see their faces
guys guys oh god oh i hear you guys i'm at the spaceship i'm
at the safe oh I got taxied back to my spaceship.
So convenient.
That's so convenient, guys.
I'm just gonna go back to the ship real fast.
I don't feel safe outside anymore.
I don't feel safe outside for content.
All right.
Just gotta make sure.
Are they alive?
Is Han alive?
Oh, Han's alive.
Okay.
Guys!
Guys Guys Guys fill me Fill me!
There's a ghost Fill me, fill me, fill me Oh my god Snuffy
Please
Oh god Someone hugged me Someone hugged me right now Oh my
god hugged me Oh thank you Do you feel better?
No, I don't feel- You need another one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need more.
My trauma is a lot.
It's okay.
I have a lot of trauma.
All right.
We're good.
Do you want your hug sheet back?
Yeah, yeah, I can hug.
Do you need hugs too, Han?
Are you traumatized?
Nah, there's no way I need hugs.
I don't need hugs.
You guys have to be hugged now.
Hey, can you hug him back to life?
guys he's a strong man I don't think I did you film the dead
body yeah yeah okay thank God at least he didn't die for
nothing guys I had a feeling that maybe Han needed that hug
just a maybe that's true for the ads guys i think we're
gonna get 3 000 wash hours this one's good i think it's
really good this one i think it's got real good potential oh
my god i can't believe it how was like vincent van go he
after he dies he becomes famous oh true here's your flash in
the hospital bill only three dollars so unrealistic yeah i
was gonna say it's kind of cheap yeah i was gonna say the
camera in Let me charge up my flashlight.
Han, I think you needed that hug, Han.
Just a maybe.
And then it will give you a CD.
You know what CD is?
This is a maybe.
These are pretty retro.
This is old world technology.
Oh my god.
We're so retro.
I heard CDs can now hold a terabyte of space.
A terabyte?
Is that a lot?
Yeah.
What is that?
I have to hold the hug you and then No, you skipped the best
part
Oh, I'm gonna go and I'm gonna go and help and
I'm running for my life Yo, it's hot
Did you get that by the fucking thing?
Oh god Is this how you lead him away?
Look at you go What's that fucking chat comment?
I didn't know threes are alive question mark
Yo, yo, snail guy, where did you get your outfit?
Where did you get your outfit?
Got it from Spencers What?
Here you go.
Yeah, yeah, I can have you.
Wait.
No, you died!
You died!
What the fuck are you filming here?
Oh, there you are.
There's a little snot creature.
What a handsome lad.
Oh my god, I think we did it!
We made the quota!
Oh, yeah, we made it easy.
We did it and we can stack the next CD to like...
The ad revenue was huge!
I know!
Oh my god, guys, I think we can...
Guys, I think we're close to taking a Raid Shadow Legends
sponsor.
I think we're going to be...
He pays so well.
Oh my god, he pays so well.
Like 500,000 of these.
Oh my god.
We're going to be so famous that Raid Shadow Legends gonna
notice us.
Raid Shadow Legends!
Brought to you by Raid Shadow Legends!
Or like, ExpressVPN.
Okay.
Oh my god!
I gotta charge my flashlight.
What?
Flashlight fully charged.
Can we afford anything?
Anybody want to videotape?
Alright, who hasn't?
Okay, I have it.
I'll videotape.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm a great camera person.
I think you should learn how to backflip snuffy.
Backflip?
Do we have enough for it?
I see yoga.
How do you backflip?
It's in the second.
It's in the first one.
It's $300.
We don't have enough money.
Carrying looks more like confused.
What is thumbnail one?
That's very intriguing.
Is he, like, reverse planking?
There's gymnastics.
We don't have enough money for a backflip.
Yeah, you gotta save up.
Oh, it sounds like it would be good.
You can add, like, a laugh track like...
Okay, you're cooler than me.
I get it.
Guys, we can make the next Big Bang Theory.
Bazanga.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
time.
Just put a laugh track so people know it's funny.
Oh my god.
Nice zoom.
Oh, this is gonna be great.
Breaking news.
Alright.
Are we ready for more content?
Yeah, yeah.
There's so many there's so many sound effects that you can
make.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I think we could get to a million views, guys.
I think it's possible.
One million?
One million, yeah!
We're gonna get one million play button.
Oh, yeah, because I'm not being, like, really meta, really
meta sounds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta be, like, super meta.
Like, game show intro.
Did no one press the button?
I won't go back.
No, no, no.
I'm like, I'm like, I got none of us press the button.
little conversation hello and welcome back to our channel
today this is day day 25 this is day 25 exploring the
caverns alright here you wait where is the cavern where are
we where the fuck where are we
oh shit what hey hey hey
all right you gotta put a sound effect while we fall down oh
my i'm okay i'm okay
all right here we go where should we go what kind of story
are we trying to tell with this next video yeah yeah what's
their story we got fake narrative well we gotta this is we
gotta make it scripted guys we all know the best content
scripted oh oh that that's that's just lime over there i
thought that was a monster okay so we gotta pay for an actor
to scare us and then make it that seem natural yeah yeah oh
no oh my god you guys wouldn't believe what i just saw okay
wait wait wait i got you boom oh my story we got it we got
it throw this at her throw the cat okay wait wait don't
worry Don't worry.
I learned this.
I learned this from a friend.
Wait, where did my camera just just fall down?
Wait, are you flying away?
I cannot just fall down.
I cannot fall down.
Wait, I can't.
You gotta hit me.
I'm trying.
Wait, where happened to the camera?
We gotta like throw something and hit her.
Wait, look somebody like climb on my head or something.
Somebody climb on her head.
I'm going to die.
I'll miss you guys.
I can't hit her!
No!
Did I hit her?
Oh, she did.
She's still hanging in death.
Oh, no.
Wait, can someone shine a flashlight on her?
Okay.
That's so fucking stupid.
Oh, yeah, dude.
Wait, wait.
Put a lap track on there again.
Put a lap track.
Okay, okay.
okay nice where the did i put my flashlight i threw my
flashlight on the floor did you guys take it oh i took it
okay okay i thought it was baby limelight okay all right
nice okay it's one of you guys should have the flashlight
because i have the camera out i got the sound effects yeah
yeah yeah okay okay hans are flashlight person
I just realized that maybe we're not good at throwing things
because all three of us unsuccessfully hit the target who's
that where is he what the fuck is that oh my god if only you
guys could see what I'm looking at right now oh my god oh
shit okay he doesn't like that
I'm the cameraman!
Oh my god!
Oh, things are happening right now!
Oh, she's dead!
Wait, she's dead?
Okay, I think we got...
Hold on, hug me.
Hug me.
I have trauma.
Tom, you need to hug me.
Yay.
It'll be all better.
Yay, can I trauma dump on you?
And that's all, folks.
All right, do you need hugs, too?
All right, nice.
All right, I still, I think we got it.
Do you think we're going to survive?
Because I still have 49% of my footage.
Do we know how to go back, though?
I already got lost.
I'm already lost.
We can survive.
Let's go.
All right, all right.
I believe in you.
Oh, what's that?
What's that?
that what's that oh is that the sky again oh no why did you
split up hide oh no down is up down is up guys down is up
down is up okay oh shit look at the sick bone right here
guys look i found a bone right here can you guys see it okay
wait wait look at the sick bone right here okay i think down
is up down is up just gotta go oh down is up I did it yay I
knew I can find my way home okay spaceship though all right
but where is oh no no flashlight oh where the fuck is that
Where is the spaceship, though?
Ooh, that is a little concerning.
Hello?
Wait, I think I hear sound effects from Han.
Oh, what the?
I can saw me.
Can I see?
Oh, I saw me!
Oh!
No!
The camera!
Oh, my God!
I can't get the camera!
The camera!
I can't believe!
Oh!
We all died!
Her ass was too big a snack.
Oh, shit!
We had a two die, huh?
How did you...
How did you die?
That was great.
Good job, everybody.
My content!
Where's my freaking content?
find the camera you can actually go back and get the camera
yeah yeah we have to get the camera what the did you die huh
who got oh what got stabbed by that guy that pupil guy oh no
we lost her hugs i can't believe i can't believe i couldn't
find the spaceship i still have the peace sign it's all
right guys we didn't lose
the way that you you guys lay down on the beds like you're
making snowing oh my god at least we made koda we did
another camera to take to find the camera yeah they give us
two cameras so we can like find the camera and then like
make more content i'm wake up a lot of money for for wake up
lime wait yeah wake up i'm awake i'm awake Gotta wake up,
man.
I've been doing content for like eight hours already.
Okay, we gotta buy the hug again.
We gotta get the hug.
Nice.
Alright.
There's all of your money.
That's all our money.
I can't believe they monetize hugs.
Is the soundboard gonna still be there too?
No.
It's only.
We gotta save up for the soundboard again.
What are you buying?
What's that?
Yeah, check it out.
Party popper?
Oh my god, the party popper!
all right we use it for like very important situation
because it's one use only like when you use it over
someone's body yeah yeah yeah very respectful or a month
yeah yeah so like when somebody dies you pop the party
popper oh we don't have flashlight guys occasionally i just
realized we spend money on party poppers and not flashlights
maybe the explosion will like light us that's okay we don't
need to fucking see it yeah we don't Our camera can see for
us I've got like I've got magnets in my head
You got the five Gs in your head What the fuck do you mean
you have magnets
Oh my god She's got the five Gs It's okay guys I've got
magnets in my head Okay Guys we gotta find a camera first No
it's a different map We can't find anything anymore Oh wait
it's the second map Wait we cannot find it even if it's like
would it be if we get that same map again will we be able to
find it i don't know first three i think the first three oh
okay so we still have the second map the second day to find
it oh this is a little spooky guys i wish we had something
that can let us see the world better oh oh it's this tabby
dude again oh it's him he killed it hold on let me flash a
peace sign with this he doesn't know yet yeah they were like
tourists you know like those like um like those like those
guys that wear those like long hats in the queen's palace i
think he's asleep sorry the king's palace oh he's not asleep
he's not asleep who woke him up oh no oh no Am I okay?
I'm fine.
Okay, okay, here.
Okay.
Hug.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Oh, don't know!
No, you fell!
Todd, you need to come down here for hugs!
Long live the king.
Oh no!
I swear.
I hope somebody stabbed you.
Oh!
Shit!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hi, Hunky, how are we going?
I need hugs.
Get here, here, here, here.
Did you grab it?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
We gotta go around.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
You didn't get me to grab it.
Oh, Han, no!
Han, drop the hugs!
Let's go, this way, this way, this way.
Did you have hugs?
Okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Give me the thing.
No, no, no.
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Just keep hugging me through the door.
the pain.
Just keep letting me through the pain.
Hug me.
You got me, though.
No!
Oh, you gotta drop the thing so I can hug you too.
I dropped it.
Where did you drop it?
I dropped it back there.
Oh, oh, oh.
Point it to me.
Oh, no.
If we don't have the thing that can let us see the ground.
I got it.
You gotta get it.
Drop it.
Drop it next to me.
Okay.
What time?
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
Run!
Oh!
Are you alive?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Keep going, keep going.
I gotta get out of here.
I don't like your chances.
Oh.
Where did you go?
Where did you go, huh?
I'm over here.
I don't know.
I'm lost.
I'm so lost!
Follow my voice.
I'm...
Ah!
See!
Han, you follow my...
Han, Han, Han, get over here!
Get over here!
Okay.
Okay, we gotta make sure.
Thank you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Your turn, your turn.
This is our only way to live.
Oh, what's that?
I heard...
Did you hear that?
That's the monster sound.
I don't think I think we should have fucking I think we
should have bought flashlights can we don't worry don't
worry it's just the snail you can't die from him he's so
weak okay huh drop the hug drop the hug I'll hug you okay
drop the hug okay here you go okay yeah are you okay now
behind us behind us Wait, wait, I hear them!
Guys!
We're lost!
Help us!
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm okay, I'm okay!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay, you're okay.
Why do you feel like you're being attacked by a straw?
No, no, no, we're okay.
I dropped the hug, it's your turn.
The cat, he can't climb.
I have to go hugging.
The cat's going hugging.
Okay, he can't.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, is that...
Is that you guys?
Hey, what's up?
What's up?
We're dead.
Oh, stop.
We are stuck.
We're sort of stuck.
So if anything happens, remember us for the content.
I will.
I think you can get up.
No, we try.
We don't know where the exit is.
All right.
Okay, okay, Han.
Follow me.
Oh.
Follow me, Han.
Okay, we go this way.
we go this way and then yeah this way this way seems like
the right way right oh this seems like the right way maybe
it's following us it's following us it's following us where
is i can't see anything i don't know what's following us oh
where are you oh what is this thing what is this thing what
What is it?
I can't I can't tell.
Are you okay?
I think you're okay.
I'm gonna go the other way Oh, I hear the bubba.
I hear the blob hot.
I hear the blob I can't see it.
Follow my voice hot Follow my voice I'm right now.
Okay, okay, okay.
There has to be a way out The fuck is that?
Oh, no, that's just a boy Okay
I think we're gonna die from the lack of oxygen.
Jump on my head.
You can do it.
Okay.
We're never getting out.
Wait.
Ah, did you...
Down is up.
Han, I went down.
Oh.
no down is always up oh one of us will live he's god one of
us will live that's all that matters oh we're gonna die from
the lack of oxygen okay down down is up down is up it's
always worked oh my god my philosophy has always than right
oh my god am i fucking gonna get out of here oh no i have so
little oxygen right now oh no oh no oh no this relies on
time now oh no i'm not gonna make it guys guys i don't think
i'm gonna make it there's so little oxygen
Oh, Doki!
Oh!
I got so little oxygen!
Yeah, we're kind of running out.
Go to the ship!
Go to the ship line!
I figured it out!
Run to the ship!
I'm here!
Help me!
I'm sorry, Han.
We don't have time anymore.
Oh!
It's the door!
Oh, Doki!
Ah!
No!
I was just there!
You didn't have to go on the second flight of stairs!
You were so close!
I saw the ship in front of me!
I literally saw the ship!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I was so close!
That guy killed me like 20 minutes ago!
I told you!
I literally saw...
That was good footage!
Oh my god, that...
I can't How did you die, Snuffy?
I got it.
I got killed by the same thing I can do.
How did you die, Han?
Snuffy, please.
Please stop.
Snuffy.
How did you die?
You died from the lack of air?
All right, bye.
I'm trying to focus right now, but for some reason, the
body's glitching and breathing in the loud man ears.
Oh, shit.
Do I still have to go to the hospital if I'm technically on
the ship?
Yeah, you do because you're fucking dead.
I kept on getting kidnapped by a cartagrade.
It was weird.
Oh my god.
I worked so hard too.
I figured I got out of the maze.
It was like floating up and down.
It was like I was leaning against the wall.
It was vibrating.
I got like a second of it before the camera ran.
Oh my god.
I actually get really lost.
I figured out how to get back and then I got fucking gunned
down.
It was so like I down is up Robert down is up you go down
and go up Was it did you get stuck in that place where
there's like just a like four corridors We don't know we
could barely see what was going on.
We could barely There's a hole in the floor underneath that
stairs.
Yeah, yeah, I got chased by a spider back there once it was
awful There were so many corridors we kept getting lost it's
okay we got content though it's very exciting footage it has
to be very good content
yo is that jokie bro let us see the world look at it oh let
me flag a peace sign with this he doesn't know yet yeah like
those like those guys that were I think he's asleep.
Oh my god!
He is coming.
Oh my god, we got 4.5k fucking views for that.
Oh my god, yeah, the views are skyrocketing.
Bro, it's going up!
It's only our third, fourth day as a content creator.
Not sure what the bones...
Hey guys.
Hey, what's up?
He's dead.
it's up to you oh snap if everything happens remember us for
the content i think you can get up we have to go around we
try oh you don't know where you know where the exit is i'm
scared oh okay 15k i think i'm gonna get attacked by bubbles
16.
hello hey you you're still having a good time now no i'm
about to get kidnapped probably i like your Oh my god,
there's like three guys down there.
There's scottling.
What the fuck?
The fucking vibrating body.
You were doing that for like the last minute, which is why I
was just stood there staring at you because it was looking
at you.
mesmerizing i didn't use anything because it was so loud are
you just listening to that yeah
it was like chow is like one minute one moment he was there
and then the next he was gone like a magic trick oh my god i
hope we can find the camera in the next one please feel free
to go get a beverage i'm gonna go buy us wait you have the
hug now right lime uh yeah okay we don't need oh yeah hold
it might need flashlight i'm gonna buy some flashlights yeah
yeah should we get the long should we invest on a long
flashlight baby if we stick together we only need like one
good one yeah all right i'll invest on the long flashlight
okay who has died the least i think limo has died the least
out of all of us because i'm a coward i mean i think you
should hold the flashlight sure that's like 200 dollars
worth oh my god hey it's not about big it's not about the
size it's how you use it it's about the ocean of the motion
it's about the motion of the
ocean what what is that how it goes about flashlights never
heard that ever in my life
What is Snuffy getting?
Is she getting water or food?
Or bathroom?
She said beverage, so I'm assuming maybe water, but maybe
alcohol.
Oh my god, what?
Maybe she needs to cope right now.
Oh shit, wait, we should film this.
We should...
Who has the camera?
Like, knocking her down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Ugh.
Oh, wrong person.
Oh, down with Snuffy.
Oh, my God.
I can't even hit her.
Holy, you took her out.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm practicing right now.
I'm practicing my karate.
Watch this.
It's like karate kid.
Joking from the top rope.
Alright, ready?
I'm going to stand up here.
Do it.
Alright, 3, 2.
one did I miss you kind of like clip the top of her head
sorry I'm practicing I'm practicing for the real deal oh I
almost pinned her down oh you try alright alright let me
push her closer to the rock oh here you go oh oh my god it's
like you're used to this You have clearly have so much
practice It's your synergy We just love knocking each other
to the floor Oh shit What happened to the synergy?
What happened?
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it Just practice.
It's just it's for play It's for play What's going on?
What's going on?
Your synergy is going away Listen listen listen Sometimes
when lots of people are watching It's harder Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
The performance anxiety.
Oh, it's a cliff.
What?
The poor.
Nothing.
Hey, Sophie, welcome back.
We're happy.
I just sat down.
What the fuck?
You woke up.
Looking on the voyeur.
Whoa.
What are you like, Chris?
We're making content.
Which side are we uploading to?
Oh.
Don't worry.
You're fine.
I don't sue.
76% film right off.
He is a professional.
All right.
I hope it's that map that I died on so we can get back the
other camera.
We need our other camera.
It's a merge.
It's called submerging.
It's just submerged.
What'd you call it?
Whoa.
Oh no, it's another map.
No.
We're never...
Is it the lower floor on the same map, I think?
Oh, on the same map?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, this flashlight's weird.
It illuminates really far away and not so much up close.
That's weird.
Oh, yeah.
You've got, like, a very nice cone shape.
Oh.
It's like I turned up the field of view really fucking high.
Don't worry.
I got my hug ready.
Is that your hole?
Is that our hole?
Oh, yeah, this is our hole.
We died.
We found your hole.
It was made for us.
Durn, durn, durn.
This was the hole.
Okay, how I figure out to go upstairs is we have to go down
and then...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What's that?
What's that over there?
Do you see that?
It's the ship.
Oh.
You mean the ship?
Oh, it looks like you had 20 eyes!
I...
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
A ship!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's lagged out here.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, if you go down, you can go up.
Oh, this is where I threw myself down when I was being
chased by a spider.
Oh, wait, this was not the same down I found.
There should be monsters down here.
You can get up from here.
What's that?
It's a hole.
You should put your face on the pounder, Snuffy.
Yeah, you want to get pounded.
Touch the pounder.
There you go.
Are you getting healed?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, that was good.
Don't worry.
Oh, nice.
Are you full HP?
I was working.
What about this?
Will this grind my bones too?
No?
No, it won't.
You should touch it.
Okay.
Are you not going to test the theory?
I got to do it for the- You're not going to get myth busted?
What's the myth?
The myth is that will it grind your bones?
Will it?
I tried.
It won't.
what the are you losing hp for that did you i'm like immune
to it wait you are oh my god you are wait oh my god myth
busted yeah i'm okay myth busted
are you are you guys just getting pounded or something no no
we're busting miss right now we're busting miss yeah yeah we
want to know if we can survive it we're invincible there's a
monster back here by the way oh yeah did you film it where
is it uh it disappeared because i tried to light on it oh is
it what this is just the dick pistons again it's this way
all right did any of us get touched by that monster for
content no it's the one that ate your ass on the first map
oh that guy oh damn okay okay all right Hello, today we're
gonna show...
Welcome to London!
World star!
It's still here.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm here!
I'll hug you!
Are you?
Oh shit!
Who's gonna hug me?
World star!
Oh my god, he's right behind us.
Hey, hey, hey.
I'm gonna hug you for a cup.
I don't know how to- Don't worry, I'm hugging you through
the- Through the pain.
Are you still getting stabbed?
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Don't worry, I can hug you through the sad things!
Oh, someone's gonna hug me!
Oh!
It's a long story, man.
Mom!
Hug!
Hug me!
I'm one inching!
I'm hugging me!
That's what?
What's up?
Oh, are they dead?
Should we leave?
No!
I swear- No!
Grab the hugs!
Hug!
Hello?
No!
One's dead.
Let's get out and hug me.
I'm never gonna be the hugger again.
The hugger never gets hugged.
The hugger never gets hugged!
What's the point?
Did you die?
I died.
I died for the content.
I'm tied for the content for the extra views.
The hugging arc is over.
No longer will I provide comfort for people with trauma.
I'll never give...
I'll never have physical touch ever again.
I'll be a bubble child.
I'll be in my little bubble.
No touchy.
I am the sole survivor.
survivor this expedition if you see this footage make sure
to like and subscribe there has to be more people still live
no one else is in that voice where are the others i don't
know where the camera is i think he died i might have to go
back there oh do they know han lived he lived wait they're
here they're here they're alive they're alive you're in the
ship already how the fuck do you know the ship i saw the guy
here the stabby guy though he was around the corner come
here yeah how did you know hey what's up oh she can't
believe us we need to look at the bottom of the map it
crashes the game
Bro, snuffy!
Bro!
The worst part is that I was spectating you.
Dude, she fell.
She fucking slipped and fell.
Oh my god.
That was really humbling.
We got the content.
We got it.
Yeah.
We also don't...
I am not the hugger anymore.
refuse to hug anymore no one ever hugs the hugger emotional
damage
what the hell is this
we're practicing for a big debut was made for me that apple
looks tasty
founder there's uh the the the scary guy that disappears and
reappears he's here oh oh that oh no that's a shaker world
star oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Wait,
where did he come from?
It's a monster mash.
That was another one.
That was so, you had like three monsters on you.
I didn't realize the other guy was there.
This expedition, if you see this footage, make sure to like
and subscribe.
Who knows what will happen.
I like that.
Just cut off before Snuffy died.
No.
I think I ran out of footage there.
The moment she slipped, it was never caught on tape.
I think the beginning was worth it.
That means we can like use our third tape for the next one.
Because we hit our quota.
We can save the next footage.
Min max.
Min maxing time.
So we need to like take a day off?
No, like we can like film it and then for we get the footage
for the next day.
I hope this game gets updated and not left to die like pal
world
that's all I want I hope this game gets freaking content all
right someone buy the hug because like I'm not the hugger
anymore I wish for it or I bring up we can either hug or I
can do a backflip it's up to you you know what i think the i
think the bath lip will be so fucking cool though imagine
the content especially if it's for content this is like a
free day this is dedicated for content so we should
definitely just i'm sure you'll do it perfectly yeah yeah
yeah me too i'm sure it'll be i'm sure that 400 would be
worth it all right i'm gonna we still afford the hug what we
still afford it all right show us the back flip how do i do
it It's T.
Press T.
Wait.
Oh.
I landed really close to the ground.
I didn't know what happened there.
You know, for first try, that's pretty good, you know, the
first try.
I think I'm good.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I think I'm doing it.
I've never seen a backflip.
I just read it in a book.
Anybody want to be the hugger?
No.
Not me.
I can do both.
Anybody want to be the video person?
Oh my god, dude.
Try it, try it.
Oh my god, the perfect hug.
All right, I'm getting some merging now.
We're submerging.
All right, here we go.
Oh, we're back here.
I knew I was.
This was worth the money.
Yeah, the $300.
laughter oh yeah do you guys know you can lead the monster
to fall to its death just try and do that and get a clip
you should find a monster and then lead him to the ship and
then watch him oh and then we're sorry we're gonna watch him
watch him die monster monster does you want to die for
content oh monster all right i'm heading up i'm going up one
small step for mankind all right hello monster monster i
have no flashlight i have no idea where i'm going oh monster
oh i found a rib cage damn rib cage Look at this.
This is what's gonna happen to you.
We don't like and subscribe to our channel.
Nice.
Okay.
Where is Lyman?
Oh my god!
There's another rib cage!
Double rib cage.
Those are the two people that didn't like and subscribe.
That's what happens when you don't click the bell button.
Yeah, this is what happens when you don't click it.
Just remember.
Wait, where are we going?
Oh, I guess parkour.
How did you guys...
I don't know.
Oh wait, this is how I got lost.
Yeah, this goes back to where we were.
Wait, no, we went down, didn't we?
We went up, didn't we?
Yeah, there's no ship.
We went up, but if we go down, we go back to the shadow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We went to go this way.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot which way I went.
Things are blurring together.
I'm surprised we haven't seen a creature.
Me too.
A creature!
Hopefully we don't jinx ourselves.
want to we want to use you for content creature i miss my
sound creature come here let us mean the one that we had in
game let us manipulate you into being your content slaves
wait wait i hear i hear london there's something behind us i
hear london it's giggling it's the london kid oh my god
where is he audio coming from where is he might have given
videos it's a fan i think he is above us yeah he's stream
sniping we're doing irl and he's trying to stream snip us
let's go investigate you guys will be seeing him very soon
oh my god guys he just wants to be on our stream he watches
our channel oh i got here oh is that him oh shit who did he
shake oh my god he's shaking in the corner he knows where
the cameraman is.
He wants all the screen time.
Oh my god.
Who has to hug?
Backflip and hug him.
He's supposed to hug him.
Yeah, he's supposed to hug him.
Oh my god.
There's two.
stream snipers.
Oh my god.
They can jump up.
They can.
No, they can.
Yes, they can.
I need it.
Oh!
Come on, you're not hugging.
Help!
Wait, where's our cameraman?
Guys?
Jesus Christ.
I've got the camera, I've got the camera.
Wait, is he dead?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, he dead.
Yeah.
He's he's he's he's dead.
Thank you for cuddling me.
He's dead.
Oh, fuck.
He got he got stream snide, man.
Oh, God.
What are you guys doing?
Here, um, somebody, somebody hold me.
Okay, don't worry.
Somebody hug you.
Okay, where is it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
It's right here.
Oh, it's here.
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
Okay.
Let me know when you feel okay now.
Let me know.
I got 28% film.
Okay, that's good.
That's enough.
Let me know when you feel okay.
Let me know.
Don't worry, I'm here for you.
Okay.
We got, I feel like let's start slowly head back to our ship
because you have 28, right?
Okay.
Yeah.
You can maybe get something on the way.
Yeah, we might as well just head back.
The turtle guy went back.
He went up the stairs.
Yeah, don't worry.
He realized there's no more.
No, they both went to the ramp, I think.
There's no more screen time for that guy.
Guys, I feel like not having a flashlight was not a great
idea.
I have one, but I also have the camera.
Does someone want the camera?
Oh, wait.
I can hold the flashlight.
This is our expensive one.
It's a skidadler.
Skidadler.
Around the corner.
Oh, check this out.
Wait, check this out.
He's slow enough.
All right, get this in frame.
Okay, okay, KK.
Wait, back up, back up.
It's so sick, though.
It's so sick.
Oh my God, you're going off.
Okay, we have to get out before she hits the bottom because
if she hits the bottom, she crashes the game.
I had a friend fall off.
She was, like, getting faster and faster and further away
because I was watching her progress on the ship.
And then when she got a certain distance away, the game just
crashed.
Oh, shit!
That's a flabber!
I'm okay!
I'm running, I'm running!
Are you still okay?
Guys, I don't think she's so okay anymore.
Guys, I don't think she's still okay.
guys where the fuck is the camera
oh my god the camera's right there
no guys if i get picked up i die
no no no no no no no no
No!
Oh, we're so close!
We're so close!
Oh my god, he picked me up!
No!
The captain!
It was a really good try.
Do you think we can find that?
It should be like right there, right?
No, this is the last day.
I like how...
I like how it's like, are you okay?
We keep losing our camera on the last day.
like I was like are you okay and you're like I think I'm
okay and then I'm like where does she go yeah he just
immediately grabbed me again and tossed me around it was
like impossible to get away oh my god did I did I fall off
the cliff with the turtle yeah he did we watched you fall oh
my god you're like I'm okay I'm okay and then we watch you
slowly fall off the building oh my god it's okay we can get
a hundred and we don't need those extra oh my god you okay
we don't need those extra 128 wait a sec this was so worth
it hey another day of content the grind never stops guys i'm
feeling good about today we lost a couple days but i'm
excited i think i feel so good too don't worry guys i have
the camera flashlights what
Oh yeah, we're doing our backflip.
It's good content.
It's extra content.
Yeah.
That was fucking sick, man.
I wish you guys saw it.
I like your popper.
Are we good?
One of those kids that just learned how to like flip in
school and they just keep doing it.
Yeah, but I don't think I don't think you've learned get
after 20 years of that.
All right, we're ready.
Are you ready, guys?
You're 28,000 years.
I'm so freaking ready.
Oh, hey, it's the first map.
Does that, wait, can we find our other camera?
I landed it that time.
I don't know, it might despawn at the end of it, like, a
section.
Is it, oh, does it, oh, it despawns after the end of the,
the, the quota?
I would think so, but it would be nice to be wrong.
chat it's time for you guys to backseat does it despawn
after for all the content creators out there who are trying
to make content does it despawn guys any backseaters in
snuffy's channel you're welcome here come back to my channel
backseaters are allowed
Stokey bird!
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, what?
What does that sound?
Oh my god!
Hey, where'd he go?
I'm scared.
I don't know.
I don't know where he went.
Oh, he fell over.
He fell over.
Oh, he's over there!
He's over there!
I see him!
He's running!
Watch me do a back clip.
All right, nice.
I think we're okay.
All right, where do we go now?
We don't have any hugs.
We're broke right now.
Nope.
He's coming back.
And we're like one of those channels that's wasted all their
money.
Fight me.
For one thing.
That's right, buddy.
Moto, Moto.
Fist to fist.
Oh my god, guys, there's a fight that's about to happen.
Guys, I'm 1 HP!
Guys, I'm 1 HP.
I'm 1 HP.
I got hit.
Wait, there's a spider, I think.
There's a spider, too!
Oh my god, today's not a good day, guys.
Today's not a good day!
Oh!
Hey guys, hey guys, there's a spider by the way.
Yeah, I could see you.
Yeah.
Did Hot have anything back?
Did Hot die again?
Did Hot, wait, someone else stick there?
Pretty sure.
I kind of do want that though.
We could check the, we could check the ship to see if...
There's something up there!
There's something in the exit!
Guys, wouldn't it be funny if there's something in front?
Holy crap!
Oh shit!
destroy What the fuck is that?
Did you guys get the camera?
Did she get the camera?
No, it's right there on stage
Holy moly that hurts so fucking bad.
Oh my god.
It's fucking stuffy I ran out of sprints.
I couldn't get away.
Totally shit.
Oh, I like how stuffy ran backwards and said up for it you
guys could have like split up and what have you made it to
the ship oh it's right in front of her it's right in front
of her i don't know if she can there's a spider too can she
outrun it oh he's so fast you smart he's so fucking smart
you know
No!
It's okay, we can grab the camera back, we can grab it back.
I don't know what to do.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Why are they all trying to- The giant was so fucking fast, I
ran out of stamina, couldn't get away.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I didn't know what to do, I didn't think I could run
either of them.
That was so scary.
That was so fucked up.
it was so don't tell me but that was like way different the
other ones are like silly and that thing like that thing
that thing too shot me bro i was already one hp and killed
her instantly and it almost fell down the stairs and then it
just stared at me
bro there was no way i was gonna live through that i i knew
i was fucked
there's somebody in front of you it's like i knew it was
over it was so over it's okay we're on day one so we can
grab our stuff back oh i hope so i really yeah let's i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go find the other camera all right we
have nothing to buy because we're broke as Fuck, let's go.
We broke this step.
Don't worry, this one's best thing.
Goodbye.
Quick, quick, press the button.
Press the button.
Alright, I knew...
Don't worry, I'll find the camera.
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll find the camera.
Wait, is this new?
No, it's the same place.
No, okay.
The camera should be somewhere around here.
There it is.
Should I just take it back to the ship?
Yeah, yeah, I think you should...
How much film do you have left?
51%.
Oh, shit, we have so much film.
The camera's broken, though.
Oh, no, it's broken.
I'll take it back.
Yeah, just throw in the...
Throw in the thing.
Do we still get the CD, though?
Yeah, yeah, we can get the CD.
We just can't film with it.
Because we got slapped so fucking hard.
I heard the slapper gives like a lot of content.
I heard that every single time it slaps, it hits the light
button.
Goodbye.
I'm here.
Wait, where's...
Where's Snuffy?
Snuffy might have ordered off.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Like, where the fuck did she go?
We gotta find the slapper.
He gives, like, a lot of views.
What's that word call when you use somebody for content?
What about their consent?
Oh, no!
What's that?
What happened?
What is that?
Oh, it's a...
It's okay.
Just walk.
Run the round.
Oh, yeah.
We're gonna exploit these monsters.
Did you exploit the monster?
It's so dark.
I don't know if my camera can see him.
Oh, no.
What about the content?
Oh, she dead?
Oh, she's dead.
Oh, wait.
Did you film?
Wait.
What's that?
Yeah, I got it.
You got it?
Okay, go back to the ship.
Go back to the ship.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Where's the ship?
Are you good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm good.
I'm walking up.
I don't know if...
alive.
We only have 80% recorded.
Okay, but if you just keep recording that one monster, I
think we can...
I don't want to be able to get a lot of views, right?
Maybe there's something up here?
Oh, that's true.
Wait, where is the... Oh, that ship is over there.
Is Han dead?
I'm gonna check the ship.
Okay.
Alright, let me check if he's dead, dead.
I can't believe we saw that.
The first thing we saw.
Alright, let's see if he's moving.
Oh, he's moving!
He's alive!
Okay, I'm gonna bait a monster near you.
Alright.
Han!
Oh hey, you're alive!
Okay, nice.
Only Lyme died.
I feel like...
We might be able to...
We might be able to find monsters outside.
I feel like we could...
Sounds scary outside.
We can't like juke them.
Oh, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Yeah, apparently they like hear our voices too.
The fitness grand pacer test is a multi-stage aerobic
capacity test.
Black and yellow, black and yellow.
Oh, there's another door here.
Maybe I'll find another monster from here.
I need my stamina though.
Monster!
We're here to exploit you for views, for content.
Monster Monster Oh What's that?
Do you hear that?
What the
fuck?
Okay, welcome Welcome to death.
I really hope they remember to pick up the camera when we
leave because I'm not sure if it will come with us if it
just sits in the thing.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, I was gonna say, did you get that?
And then I died.
I Don't know how to deal with that monster once it gets you
it just chain throws you and you fucking die It's a like
make another person aggro it before it picks you up again I
guess the aggro it Got you Oh god, they have to go home.
Just go home.
We got the content Yeah, how do you not have more content?
How about we going stay over here?
Oh, he's going to be a bait.
I die for the content.
He's going to do it.
Take the film back.
Okay.
No.
Snuffy, what are you doing?
Why are you still walking following him?
She good.
Talented.
Lucky.
I think they're going to die, Lai-mu.
I think...
They're so fun.
How much...
Yeah.
There's so...
Everything...
I have come to bring Kusil.
Just becomes really fucking lethal.
So nice.
That nice stuff?
Themself?
Yeah.
Thyself!
I trust the vision.
I trust it.
It's too dark and I can't find you.
We can do it.
There's no way...
I just realized there...
Oh, it's a little snail.
That's okay.
The spookiest of monsters.
A snail.
What is this, Mr. Snail?
Oh, ha ha ha ha!
So spooky.
We still have 30%, but maybe we'll catch something on the
way out.
He's a natural content creator.
Very much, sir.
We're pretty...
I feel like we have good odds to re-encounter something.
I don't know.
They're so dead.
There's no way.
I don't think they're going to make it to the ship.
We've always got, like, fucked up the last possible second.
Hello.
Go up.
What are you guys doing?
Your oxygen.
Mr. Conter?
Oh.
How much oxygen do they have left?
Look at their back in the canister.
Oh, shit.
That's not a lot.
Yeah.
That's why I was like, why are they still exploring?
Oh!
Yes, Han?
Uh.
Han?
That only happens if you don't die.
What was that?
Our entire life relies on snuffy now she doesn't know where
to go oh she does okay i thought it couldn't smother her
bones we literally myth busted that oh no no not the
monster's gonna grab her at the very end oh no we needed you
at the bait Oh, she's so close to the ship, though.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, fucking...
I can't...
Oh, my God!
He's fucking kidding me!
Wow!
Now that's two cameras!
Do we not get that bad?
We put the camera in the spaceship maybe it came back.
Is it still there?
Oh, we put the first okay We just got back.
Oh my god Holy shit.
It's back.
Okay, we got the listed camera.
Oh my god.
This we can afford flashlights now Yeah, that means we can
go back that one was good content.
Yeah.
We gotta go back for it.
We gotta find the camera
All right, I have the cd.
Let's go Oh my god, is this the one where I recorded it?
Oh my god, it's gonna be so good.
I don't even remember what happened.
This feels like a week ago.
That was fucking sick, man.
I wish you guys saw it.
Backseat, you're coming to my channel.
Oh my god!
What is that?
It's the villain, it's not just the world!
Oh my god, guys, you're such a liar.
Fire, too!
Oh
my god.
Look at the views!
What's the slider?
How did you get 65k from that?
Because I got body slaps!
It was like a selfie the entire time and they were like, we
love this.
We love this content.
I was fucking good.
I want to see that one again.
That was so good.
All right, here we go.
time to sleep I'm gonna stay up all night watching this I
can't believe I can't believe this that was like the most
views we've ever had too I forgot about the whisk guy that
feels like so long ago all right sleep time sleep time yay
oh my I got apparently YouTube's broken right I'm literally
streaming this content It's like already on my platform
We're doing so well guys I believe in us I mean we can I
think we can I think if we get our second camera We'll be
fine Apparently YouTube's broken right now And because I
went from like Apparently I have like 300 people watching me
Because YouTube broke They were They said Yes, spider, we
didn't listen.
Yes, there are like too much spiders.
Okay, what do we need?
What do we need to survive, guys?
We need...
We definitely need the hugs.
Wait, wait, wait, we need the defib.
We need a defib.
We can afford a defib and the hugs.
Oh, that'll be great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Infinite life hack.
Yeah, infinite life hack.
Okay, do we order it?
What do we order?
What is in our fucking bin right now?
I'm scared.
We can, oh, we can afford flashlights.
I'm gonna order a flashlight for us.
We have so much money.
Is it good to just, like, buy a ton of shit now?
Yeah, I mean, we need it.
We really need it.
There's no reason not to, I guess.
The fuck is this?
The chivalry letter.
Oh.
life hack oh yeah i'll be the healer oh you want it okay
here you go all right guys chat you're all here go for it
you go for it even if i have one fat if dokey bird has one
fat i'm one of them if dokey bird has zero fans it's because
i'm dead that's you you guys are the chosen all all 200 of
you
It blows out the audio even more.
It's really funny.
Oh, shit.
Did you guys got the flashlight?
Defib and the...
I got the flashlight.
Alright, alright.
Not a Defib.
Nice.
Oh, we don't have any money.
That would be... That's real.
Yeah, that's real.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
We're broke now.
We gotta find the camera.
all right does anyone okay the camera has to be like on
almost close to us i'm gonna go find the camera it's over
here to the left it should be it's near the other entrance
i'll try and find the
camera don't worry let's split up gang that's why i learned
how scooby-doo
Yeah, what we learn in Scooby-Doo If Scooby-Doo can do...
Oh, I found it!
Oh, wait, no, that's... That's... Wait, is that you?
Do you find the camera?
It's gotta be around there.
Yeah, it should be around here.
That's where she got slapped.
Right?
What the fuck is her camera?
It's right here.
Oh, okay, I grab it.
There it is.
It's underneath the bones here.
I'll grab it.
Okay, you're gonna take it?
Okay.
Yeah, I'll take it back.
Alright.
Oh, it doesn't...
Someone want the flashlight?
Yeah, I can take it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have 85%.
All right, let's put the camera.
Let's make sure she, let's escort her, give a buddy system,
and make sure she makes it to the ship.
Okay, okay.
Let's make sure she doesn't die while we walk back and get
slapped.
It doesn't look like there's anything.
That's nice.
Wait, Snuffy, did you get footage of the slapper?
I think I did I did okay good I hear he's like a lot of
views yeah really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like a
combination of like the both the times we died okay there we
go all right nice I was like if I'm dying it's for the
content you know exactly it's all about going viral for the
content if you don't die for your content
do not listen to me it's not really good advice where oh my
god he's the fucking stream sniper yeah give him some of
that content yeah he wants to be a famous stream sniper you
can become famous that way guys then like oh my gosh there's
like so many big streamers that became famous stream
sniping.
But also don't stream snip us, guys.
You won't get famous from stream sniping YouTubers.
It only works for IRL content.
Here we go.
Content.
Content time.
Where are you?
I don't know if there's any cool new monsters.
You don't know that.
There could be a...
Oh, it is a dead end.
Guys, it is a dead end.
Oh, it's a dead end.
Wow, look at that.
Wow, who would have thought?
Guys, why didn't you tell me it was a dead end, guys?
I'm surprised we haven't found the lasers yet.
We could have done some limbo.
We could go this way.
Oh my god, apparently YouTube is broken that people can't
chat right now, but they can super chat.
oh my god you gotta pay the chat it's pay to win pay the
chat if you want to communicate with a streamer you gotta
have the money that's so fucked up wait there's a spine did
you guys get me did you film the spine oh shit someone's
going to hug you Someone quick hug him He's got the hugs
wait, you have the hugs I've got you Thanks, all right film
the hugs I'm full healed thank you Thank you, Jesus Christ
Guys, I'm stuck could I have a hug?
I'm feeling very vulnerable right now Guys, oh yeah, I'm
okay.
I'm okay.
Who has the hugs?
Oh, he's back!
He's back!
I flashed him!
I don't think he liked that.
Yeah, no, he doesn't like the light.
I would like a hug.
Thank you.
There we go.
I'm just like, thank you.
Yeah, he doesn't like light, so...
Don't worry, I have the light!
I got it!
Wait, we got it!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
have the flashlight all right i have the defib too how much
more film do we have left we only have 20 or i think that's
enough yeah we should head back there's gonna be a giant up
there anyway yeah i feel like we're gonna get over again
wait what's where's this way oh they run off their oh yeah
don't worry i'm never lost no of course not don't worry i
got this guys don't worry I am very very much almost out of
oxygen Did he squeeze the oxygen out of my ass I think he no
no we're the same Did he squeeze the He was trying to
fucking perform CPR But fucked up There's something over
there on the right hand side I don't know what it is Where
is that?
Chris?
Where?
Where is it?
Is it the stream sniper again?
Stream sniper?
Where is it?
Did you lie lie?
I'm okay okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I dropped my
flashlight we don't need it it was a cheap one I got it I
got it it was a cheap one don't worry it's okay guys where's
the camera where's the camera okay let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go Oh
my god, we lived!
Guys!
We've lived!
We finally lived!
Okay.
We have to figure out if the first camera or the second, the
first camera would give us the views or not.
Or should we just commit to the last one?
The first one might have giant footage.
We could do that.
Alright.
Okay, we'll do the first then.
all right okay and then we'll save the other one we suddenly
make a cd out of it i grabbed it is this the first one is
this the first one that's the broken one the broken one okay
wait do an emote toss the toss the non-broken one in any way
ciao ciao
That's good.
That's all we need.
Alright, I got the film.
Dude, do we get double movie night?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
We save the other.
If we don't make enough views, we can use it.
But for now, we'll do this one first.
Okay.
Did you backflip?
No!
You backfliped!
What is that, Snake Mech?
I'm gonna check the ship.
Okay.
The hero returns.
Do you hear that?
Someone just said ha ha ha like malicious in response to me
fucking dying.
What a dick.
You fuck are you team bagging?
What the fuck?
What the fuck, guys?
She found out.
By self, yeah.
By self.
The spookiest of monsters.
A snail.
Just heard a scary noise might die
Where the fuck is the slapper?
It's just like one second of the slapper Just heard a scary
noise might die.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta save the other CD that was many views
did you guys get the other one um yeah yeah we gotta save it
for next time we finally are able to save the cd we can hold
on to it right where is the other cd no who has it i don't
have it what happened did someone if we sleep if we sleep um
it'll uh respawn oh no it's in the tray it's in the tray
it's right over here yeah yeah okay we don't have to worry
we can just sleep now okay all right we'll be fine Don't
worry that I got good views today.
That's all that matters.
Alright.
Three days left.
Good morning everybody.
Are you guys ready for more content?
Yeah.
We need 325k views now.
Jesus.
That's a lot.
That is a lot of views.
Wait, what?
What?
What did you spy?
Is that...
What is that?
Anybody like this?
Is that the ancient gesture?
Is that the...
Is this the gesture I think it is?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it is.
Is it?
I think you deserve it.
Okay, I deserve.
Oh, it is.
Oh, my God.
We have one dollar left.
But it was fucking worth it.
Wonderful.
Yeah, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We got the green screen.
Let's green screen this.
Wait, wait.
Someone come to the...
Where's the green screen?
Here, here, here, here.
Okay.
On the moon.
It's like I'm on the moon, guys.
Oh my god, she's back flipping on the moon.
Oh my god.
There's no gravity, dude.
Oh my god, it's sick, dude!
Oh shit!
You can slip off the dolphins.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Yeah!
Okay, I know this is gonna actually film the monsters.
World tour.
Okay.
Make them wait till the very end.
That's like our channel intro.
That's a big font on top of that.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Don't mind what the heck.
All right, here, I'm ready.
Oh, this flashlight's great.
Look how much light I get here.
I got the defib.
Nice.
So like, if we die, I have the defib reader.
This is the best flashlight.
Nice.
Oh wait, is this a hole that we can jump down here?
Okay.
Who has the camera?
I do.
Okay, watch this.
Oh wait, no, not yet.
Not yet.
I fucked it up.
Okay, watch this.
Watch this.
God damn it.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I can do this.
One more time.
What the fuck?
I'm floating.
It was worth it.
It was worth it, guys.
I used like 20,000.
5% of film there.
It was worth it.
We could get so much content.
Whoa, did you guys hear that?
Oh, no, it was the door.
We gotta find what down is up.
See, look, down is up.
I told you.
Look, there's a thing here.
It's up here this way.
Can we not go up here?
Where did this go?
Wait, I feel like, let's split up, gang.
Wait, who has the camera?
What's the point of splitting up and making it?
He's recorded.
You don't know that?
We could like find him in another area.
Wait, where did you guys go?
Hello?
Hello, guys?
Guys, I can hear you say keep moving forward!
Guys, really?
Cease?
Guys, guys, guys, don't worry.
Ah!
Oh my god, who shot?
Guys, guys, what's that?
Guys, are you guys okay?
Oh my god, it's a slapper!
Did you get the content?
Run, run, run, run!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the camera's so good.
There's a snail too!
Run, run, run, run, run!
Live!
You're alive!
Live when you're alive!
There she is!
She's coming back to life!
Fucking... Does she AFK when I revived her?
I think she... I think she...
Oh, jeez!
maybe she'll pick it up maybe she'll realize did she fucking
oh my god did she like i got she was like what
oh my god mother fuck
wow did you like did you a you have the magnets in your head
what the hell did he just teleport onto me he literally like
he ran straight at you bro bro did you like afk when you did
you afk when i revived you i i i was like okay i'm dead so i
tabbed and went to go deal with my dog and then suddenly
like i was alive i was like run run run livo and then i died
and then i just see I was like, okay, I'm dead.
Perfect.
Time to go take care of some chores.
Nope.
And then I came back and I was like, wait, how am I alive?
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh.
About to revisit my grave.
Yeah, that guy fucking teleports, I swear to God.
Walk back.
He gets slapped.
Oh, it's not.
It doesn't look like there's anything.
It's gonna be the first guy I want to see.
What?
I was with fucking Tomberry again.
Damn it.
Oh my god.
He's a fucking stream sniper.
All right, well get to milking.
Get to milking.
For the condom.
Milking him.
Yes.
Oh my god.
You're almost in red super chat?
Got content.
Who did it?
Where are we looking?
Oh there he is.
Oh god.
He doesn't know who to go.
Okay
Look at our views though look at it go up.
Oh my god 165.
Did we find a slapper here?
Yeah No, we didn't we found like the regular guys Yay As
long as we find our other camera, we can get a lot of views
because we filmed the slapper.
Oh my god, thank god we have money, we're broke, we don't
have anything again.
Oh my god, we're always broke.
That's our secret.
We live to survive.
Good morning.
Morning.
friends into a 1000 deep tunnel for seven days you forgot to
add for seven days for seven days i think you stranded on
ancient technology yeah we need a flashlight a hug and a
deep pip do we have enough yeah i'll put the that's a 500
flashlight imagine how bright it could be okay we have 400
left should we spend it on the long flashlight i like the
modern flashlight better okay yeah we'll buy two then hell
yeah wait i don't think we have enough yeah we don't we
don't have enough i couldn't math i couldn't math why would
you rely on me on mathematics hon you know i can't do math
all right I got the modern flashlight I should Wait I'll be
at the start of the show I'll be at the defib Let me know if
anybody wants the camera Alright I'm ready No I don't like
the pressure Yeah the pressure is big too much Are you guys
ready We gotta find the camera Does anyone remember where it
was Does anyone remember Wait what we died I don't remember
much of anything
oh wait wait baited to to its death he's gonna he's gonna
fall off because he doesn't know what to do okay he's gonna
fall off right he doesn't look like he's falling off film
him film him film him film him free content
What happens if I...
Oh god, this is funny.
Guys, we had to hurry.
Get the camera before you...
Oh, there's a calm monster!
There's a monster!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Fight me dead!
Ah!
Defend me!
No!
You deserve that.
What did I do?
Yeah, no, thank you.
You killed me.
I didn't know.
I opened the door.
That's different.
I'm back.
I opened the door.
Thank you.
I didn't want to hear Han yell at me.
Here's your defense.
Oh, it's not me still with the camera.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, she found the camera?
No.
Okay, we have, we have, I don't remember how far they've
been called.
It's not that far.
Okay, what, okay, let's just try and find the other camera.
We just need the other camera.
Does anyone, oh.
Do you, do you, I don't know.
What the fuck is that?
It's like, it's a mouse.
We gotta figure out how to find it, where the other camera
is.
Where could it be?
Was it above us?
Okay, I think, yeah.
No, it would have fallen.
No, I meant like the second camera.
The camera we died with.
We gotta figure out how to...
It should be above us, right?
There's something in here.
Oh no, we don't have a camera to catch it, too.
Nope.
Oh no.
It's making plopping noises.
I'm kind of uncomfortable, actually.
Me too.
It's getting closer.
Oh god.
Limeo?
I think they hit terminal velocity.
Oh.
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
When you fall for a certain amount of time, it crashes the
game.
Did you crash too?
What the fuck?
Yeah, yeah.
If someone falls.
Wait, I'm still in the game.
I'm still in the game.
It just works.
Well, I think we were...
Well, actually, I don't know.
I don't think we were screwed.
That super sucks.
We haven't come back yet, though.
Wait.
No, I think I gotta restart the game.
Oh, shit.
I'm still in the game.
I'm still in.
Guys, I was still in the game.
Oh, you were?
Yeah, I'm still.
We crashed.
I wasn't even the server owner.
Wait, how was the server owner?
Han, you gotta remake the server.
Huh?
I would make the server.
We had terminal velocities, so everything was crashed.
Okay.
All right, let me...
I've been disconnected.
I'm going to wait for the invite.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe I opened the door.
You put me four all the way down there.
How is I supposed to...
I just opened the door.
Oh, I wonder what's keeping them anchored down inside the
ship.
You know, maybe he's glitched or something.
Like, just open the door.
Okay, you walked into him.
That was your fault for walking into the guy.
And you kicked me off the cliff.
We had a defib and everything.
We were planned for this.
It was for the content.
Yeah, we were so planned.
Yeah, defib me freaking 100,000 meters below the surface.
You were falling definitely.
So fast.
Wait, wait, wait.
It didn't count the day.
oh result wait what does that mean it meant okay wait stuffy
in here wait they're all gone they left me stuffy's down
here i like i was like we left her yeah so i guess i guess
we get like a redo oh my god that was such good content when
hawk fell down the shit that was such good content we missed
out all right let's wait for snuffy where is she oh what
color am i am i so red i am nice
oh it resets the volume of everybody too i'll just notice it
resets everybody's volume uh i can't invite snuffy for some
reason i can invite her all right or a lime can uh yeah i'll
invite her yeah yeah one of us can invite her how do i join
the game i just invited you it's just like how do we get in
here hey hey reset the day so we get another chance we have
another chance backflip anymore oh my god you're right we
lose our emotes oh and it wipes i remember it wipes the
camera too oh my settings are different it wipes the camera
as well so like uh we we won't be able to grab the camera
from the last day because we have to reset it we don't even
think about it bro but it has to slap her though we buy the
d5 oh yeah that's true he might slap us again i'm gonna grab
grab the d5 and the hug all right we're so back guys i have
oh my guys guys i'm blowing up i don't have 200 viewers
anymore guys oh my god i'm going viral live at this moment
dude oh my god the slapper did you get slapper content yeah
i got this like they heard about the slapper content oh my
god i'm going viral as we speak going from a 200 andy to a
to a 4k andy someone grabbed a hug freaking miracle come
here backseeding work backseeding work what what what look
it's our it's our it's our items oh it's our ancient justice
i don't remember which one's mine oh my god i could yours is
the peace side what is this nice nice nice yeah yeah i'll
never bought it emote guys and you said you were gonna bat
all backseaters i've been changed yeah they got me back my
back Thank you, backseaters.
You gotta unban the backseaters now.
You gotta do those streams where it's like...
Our crew three times that size too.
Alright, are you ready to go?
Are you ready for content?
Yes, dude.
Yes, content, content.
Content time.
We're so back.
Wait, what's that?
Wait, what do you order?
Oh.
Did you order the goo?
I saw that.
You ordered the goo, didn't you?
You're gonna goo them, aren't you?
You can't.
You can't, you can't, no.
I saw, I saw what it was.
We're so back.
We can do this.
We can get 300.
Oh, oh, there's no way we can die this time too, because
there's no, no, no hole.
Yeah, there's no holes.
There's no holes.
Yeah, there's definitely no way we'll die in another way.
Wait, but then the content, okay.
For content though?
Yeah, for content.
I have a defib, guys.
I have a defib, so you die.
be stuck up there aren't you no no we can just chuck it i
want to do it i'll defib three two one who's gonna do it who
has the least important items i have a flash i am going i am
going i start screaming oh god no what a world oh my life
hey thank you i did it you have to chuck it at them yeah
yeah yeah you'll try again i'll show you a demonstration
line do it again it'll be so funny can someone hug me first
i feel very vulnerable thank you thank you i feel brave
enough trauma is it real let's do this let's do this it's
true is it real okay go outside oh god no i'm so vulnerable
i'm scared oh my work is gonna take forever holy don't worry
i can do it i can replicate this okay there you go see
that's Thank you.
That's how you do it.
A hug.
Uh, can I have another hug, please?
It's still feeling really emotional.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Let me give it back to you as well.
Thank you.
I thought...
Oh, fuck!
Holy stuff, enough!
Guys, it's my turn!
I taught you this!
I taught you, guys!
I hit you with it!
There you go.
There's a bone.
I got a bone, though.
Hey guys.
It's like when a Looney Tunes character steps on a
shovel-type moment.
Yeah.
You know what grabbed?
Oh, you have the defib, right?
I got bone, though.
Look at this.
Look at the sick bone.
Oh, it's right behind you, I think?
This.
Yeah, I dropped the...
Oh!
Tombery!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, shit!
Oh, God.
Help me!
Oh, no!
Okay.
Wait, did he die?
Did he got shot?
He got shaped to death!
Don't worry, I'm the defense!
Where is he?
Oh, look, there's goop.
There's goop right here.
Where's his body?
He's still in my thing.
There's go.
There you go.
Don't worry.
You're alive!
Han, you're alive!
Get down from here!
Han!
Get chucked him down!
Oh my gosh.
He's done it again!
You've done it, Han!
Han!
You should have bought an Emo.
Wait, there's a slime!
Oh god.
No, it's his slime!
He spent our money on that slime!
Guys, we have to get him down because there's a cool down
for him.
The shooting robot!
The shooting robot on the grabby hook!
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
He was so doomed.
No, we're fine.
No, indeed.
Did I revive you and you were just still stunned?
Were you still alive when you were trapped?
It's very time again.
Oh my god, did she get the content, no?
Did she get the content?
I think she has to go.
I think she has to leave.
I need to go get everybody's...
What?
No, just leave.
Just leave.
It's not worth it.
At least if she dies, she could just leave the camera here,
maybe.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Oh, see.
Gigabrain.
Yeah, yeah, but the thing is, there's like three monsters
outside.
I can literally hear it.
We can literally hear, like, them pulsating.
Yeah, they're pulsating against the door right now.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nobody's there.
What's the worst that could happen?
She dies?
That would be so funny, though.
I like how she's looking at the ground.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
It's right there.
No, no, no.
Oh, yeah, I don't see it.
Oh, I see it now.
He brought like a...
I feel like we just got, like, ganged up.
I hope she remembers the ceiling guy.
Oh, that would be so funny if she doesn't remember.
Wait, there's two of them there.
I liked how Han inked with the goo When he got like He like
instantly threw the fucking goo Oh Oh Where is she trying to
do I can't I don't think she sees our bodies over there Yeah
I was gonna say
Her face properly Her face properly represents what's the
slime too Just just leave we can buy new items just leave
Where did you where did you go?
Just leave Guys apparently Apparently you can charge your
items if you hold q i just figured it out All on my own,
what do you mean charge them?
You hold your q you throw you can throw them higher I just
figured it out myself the apple was not like at all a
satisfying Can she still use it will you die?
Oh No, I'm still dead.
I got baited.
I'm so dead I got baited I was dead for too long.
Where the fuck did you go?
Okay, whatever My defense I'm leaving
Oh, no, no, are you fucking kidding me?
I'm out.
Five.
What the fuck was that?
Did you see that?
Wait, what?
I haven't seen him.
There was, like, something behind her.
All right.
We're back.
Look at that.
Two dollars of hospital bills.
We didn't hurt too hard.
I tried to fall through the world again.
I defibbed you and you immediately started falling.
Wait, that's what happened?
Yeah, yeah, no.
Your body started falling.
I was like, well, I was like, I'm back.
I was like, JK, I'm still dead.
I got baited.
Yeah, no, I, like, I went back to the ship and your body was
like...
I was just not here.
All right, we got...
We have really good content for this.
I did save this, so here you go.
Here's your defense.
Oh my god, I'll charge it.
Oh, wait, it's fully charged already.
Nice.
That's good, because Zifa was like $300.
I couldn't find a flashlight, unfortunately.
It's alright.
Flashlight's so replaceable Don't walk into it Don't walk
into it We're gonna do it who has the least important items?
I have a flash.
I am going The way you slowly walk there's screaming What a
world My wife is watching before my eyes.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm feeling brave enough now.
All right.
Let's do this.
Let's do it this looks like you're shooting hoops he's right
here he's still the thing he's still the thing i was really
impressed by that
Gabby has dudes!
No!
She, he wanted to get involved with the basketball.
Oh, you missed the part where he threw Doki directly at me
and we both died.
I literally, I really love the explosions.
The Doki collision.
They're right behind me, aren't they?
I don't even sound like they're playing sick beats.
I can't remember right.
Holy shit.
It was like, oh my god, we're so close.
We got to 30,000 meters before I allowed.
oh that was close you almost we almost crashed the server
again oh my god and that was so scary because you didn't
fall for me like i wouldn't even know i like the vibrating
haunt there on the fucking the monster it just starts
vibrating okay last day for content we gotta make we can't
die for this one okay we can't die we can't the hugs and the
flashlight i don't have anything what did we buy blink all
right flashlight and hugs the jokie lesion all right we got
the hugs are you guys ready last day for content last day we
can do this we can get 325k viewers so easily yeah yeah yeah
Yeah, yeah.
And Logan Paul can, if our Oshi Logan Paul can do it, so can
we.
Bro, he's like a millionaire now!
He owns Prime!
Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime.
Like the Amazon?
What?
Wait.
Did you just say the Amazon?
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Is that the slapper?
Yeah, it is.
Go back!
Oh my god!
Did it hit me?
No!
Just found the contour!
Oh my god, hug me!
Oh my god, do you have the hug?
I don't know where the camera is.
No, I saw her.
She was behind us and she was behind.
I might be dead.
Oh my god.
It was either Snuffy or Mermaid either.
We need to go get the camera.
He's camping the room.
I can see him.
Okay, okay.
I'll stay here.
Okay, no, no.
Use me as bait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't hear you anymore.
No!
It's okay.
We can do this.
I remind you.
They took your voice.
Okay.
We don't need to know.
We can do this by spirit.
Oh, there you go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
They don't need, doesn't need my voice.
Okay.
We can figure this out.
Okay, here's the plan.
That's not the plan.
If you can, I can't hear you.
If you can hear me, you keep the items.
You stay here.
I'm gonna make a hero run.
Okay.
When he fucks off.
Yeah, fantastic.
Yeah.
Here we go.
When he leaves.
Jesus Christ.
I don't think he's gonna leave.
And you know, if I die, I'll stop moving and then you can
come out and rest me.
It'll be great.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Bro.
Stop camping.
Oh no.
He's camping us.
Why was he here?
Wait, can you hear someone die?
Wait, it's the shaker.
What the fuck is that?
It's the shaker.
It's London!
It's London again!
Oh no!
This is our last day, too!
It's not leaving!
I kind of want to open it.
I wish I could hear you.
Sometimes I can still hear your voice.
Don't talk.
Stop laughing!
I don't think they're going to leave.
Stop talking!
Wait.
It's going quiet.
Why does it sound like one of them is flying?
Shut the fuck up, I move!
Okay.
I'm going to go for it.
Where do...
Let's see.
Neither of them are further than 50 meters away.
There's, okay, the camera must be close.
Here we go.
I see the fucking Tomberry.
Okay, wish me luck.
Bye, Doki.
Bye.
Do you think she's alive still?
Yeah.
Stop moving.
She's still moving.
I think it's okay.
No, she's still alive.
41.
She is still running.
She's running really fast right now.
I think she's getting chased.
She's...
Oh, she stopped.
Wait, no?
Oh, she's...
She stopped.
Ah.
No, she stopped.
Yeah, she stopped.
She's dead.
No, she's 100% dead, guys.
She's so dead.
No!
Okay.
Gotta be quiet.
Oh no, it's a shaker.
Oh no.
No.
No, please.
Let me get to them.
I'm trying to find the camera.
I don't even have hugs.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't even have hugs!
This is the last day!
No!
Oh my god!
Oh!
It's right there!
Yeah!
No!
We failed!
We failed to gain popularity!
No!
I got chased by two of them two of them are running circles
shanking me oh my god you think this was a good time to call
it I got the camera but then they shanked me twice it was
awful guys it was a great time having you guys as my content
team good job but i think every channel deserves to die at
some point we gotta do our own solo careers guys we have to
break up and to be our own let's plays but they didn't want
to listen we all gotta separate and make our own channels
and get our own play button i'll die out there
the group hunt you have a personality i don't know how to
transition out of this i'm gonna die no my content dried up
you do not need to be restricted as a group collaborator you
can do solo content too i have views on youtube i'm gonna
start streaming don't make me start streaming no that was
fun i had a great time Thank you.
I got a great time.
It was so nice to meet you, Daimu.
It was wonderful meeting you.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming and hanging out.
Yeah.
I will never hit a million views.
This was like the same area where I died too in my last
collab.
I didn't get past 300.
It's because our flapper keeps showing up and wiping us.
Bro, like, how could, how the fucking, we just got there too
and he just showed up.
Yeah.
He was just like, hey.
I'm gonna ruin your whole career.
Yeah, we never got chance to afford a stun gun because we
kept dying.
We kept wiping out.
That's so fucked up.
We got stream sniped to the point we had to get a stun gun.
Guys, we should have.
Guys, we should have hired a bodyguard instead of somebody
that fucking hugs.
The content is even raw.
The raw content.
People want the emotional.
They want those hugs.
Ruralness Okay, thank you guys for playing.
Yeah, thank you guys.
GG's everyone.
Thank you all for joining us too.
Geez, I'm going to sleep after this.
Oh, yeah, you're fucking lagging us all.
Nice meeting you guys.
All right, I'll see you guys.
Bye bye.
Oh my god I can't believe it.
We died in the same place.
This is the same same view count we're never gonna hit a
million we'll never hit a million but it was great i had a
great time with all of them um it was really nice to meet
limu for the first time um han was extremely jet lag he was
telling us before we started the stream that he was like
still suffering from jet lag because he because he's been
like you know he hasn't been in na time zones for like a
couple of months now so he was like yeah i should be
sleeping right now and i was like Oh, I'm sorry, I had a
great time.
It was really great meeting Limu and doing a collab with her
for the first time.
And it was really fun.
Hey, I was Snuffy again, too.
Really great chemistry with Snuffy.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that was so funny when YouTube died.
I was like, holy shit.
I was like, oh my God, I fell off.
knew eventually I'd fall off I was like what the fuck oh my
god I was like bro how did I drop from 6k to fucking 200 I'm
like I knew it it was only a matter of time when I was about
to fall off I fucking knew it
I fucking knew it
I okay even if i fall off at least i have you dragoons
that's super dedicated ones um but it was a great time i
love how like that's so fucked up when like you have to pay
to chat that was so fucked up i was like we were like we can
only chat by super chatting i'm like oh my god That's so
fucked up, bro.
YouTube.
Dark Plane.
Thank you for listening.
For chat.
Thank you.
That was really funny.
I hope you guys had a great time.
I'm going to call out here, everybody.
My voice is dying.
So I'm going to rest up.
Tomorrow is also a rest day.
So I get to rest a double.
But yes.
I hope you guys enjoyed the collab, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
of you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye